Charlie starts off this hour in Phoenix
hi Charlie how are you near-perfect
daven you just the same sir how can I
help
very good Dave I've been following your
program for three for three years paid
off 69 thousand dollars and in 14 months
and my question to you at age 52 I've
been putting in about 15% into my floral
401k for the last several years and it's
approximately at two hundred and
seventy-five thousand good for you well
thank you my question to you is at the
age of 52 should I stop putting in the
15% and only put in the match and put
more into a Roth IRA
well I you're still paying off a home
right uh well I could actually pay or I
could actually sell a rental that has
$100,000 of equity in it and pay off my
primary home which only has about a
hundred thousand dollars left on it and
it's valued at about four hundred
thousand income a hundred and forty
thousand okay so you're going to pay the
house off anyway even if you don't sell
the rental it's you're on track to beat
it down right correct okay and so I'm
going to continue with baby steps four
or five and six and that's 15 percent of
your household income going into
retirement and if you have kids college
you need to be doing we're doing that
and anything extra we can find we start
throwing at the house which brings us
back to putting fifteen percent of your
income into retirement does it all have
to go into the 401k no it does not
I would take it out take your 401k up to
the match and then I would do a couple
of Roth IRAs you're over 50 you can do
sixty five hundred each that's thirteen
thousand a year and then if you need to
do a little bit more to get to fifteen
percent of your income then you do a
little bit of non matching in the 401k
to get the math to balance out okay I do
have fifty thousand dollars saved for my
son's college he most likely will stay
here in Arizona and at a 4.3 grade point
average most likely he'll get a
at academic scholarships somewhere so
excellent we're we're pretty good at
this point
well he's killing it congratulations
that's neat okay yeah you're set on that
and so the point is I don't want you
throwing 20% into retirement by messing
around with three or four different
things I only want to put fifteen
percent in there because I want you to
throw the rest of it at the house I
wanna get that house knocked out without
having to sell the rental to do it and
you're going to be there you're right on
track you're killing it man you're doing
great
that's what well thank you I mean I
loved your program went to Financial
Peace University just looking at what's
the next step for me so yeah you're you
know you get 300,000 saved you're 52
years old you're on your way or 275,000
so I was reading an article the other
day by this crazy left-wing liberal type
that was saying the 401 K is the biggest
scam ever perpetrated on the American
public and since you're sitting there
with 275 thousand and I guess you
wouldn't agree with that no yeah I
talked to millionaires all the time that
they're you know a whole bunch of their
net worth or million dollar net worth is
in their 401k I don't think they think
it's a scam so yeah the 401 K is not a
scam that's just a ridiculously ignorant
statement and I've heard that two or
three times lately it's just people of
losing their dadgum minds out here some
of these people that get stuck down in
these rat holes and they can't see
reality because of the people they're
hanging out with and it's just as crazy
so Charlie you're doing great you're
doing great man keep it up so proud of
you yeah you're going to end up work
being worth several million dollars by
the time you get to 65 some of that's
going to be your paid for house some of
that's going to be the the close to a
million dollars that by then you have in
your 401ks and in your Roth IRAs so
you're living the great American dream
dude you did it you're on your way
congratulations
open phones this hour a triple eight
eight two five five two two five now
let's stop at just a second and remind
you that being a millionaire is a good
thing a millionaire is someone who what
you own minus what you owe is a million
dollars so with your 401 K and you're
paid for house if you have a million
dollar net worth that's a good thing
to millions twice as good and five
millions five times as good does that
answer all of life's questions is that
the only goal you have for your life
will not less you're shallow if money is
all you're after then you're shallow but
the point of having a net worth like
that the point of having built some
dollars up is to be able to take care of
yourself in retirement and not be
counting on the government which is well
known for its ability to handle money
also just security I'm not worried about
Social Security I'm okay only thing I'm
worried about is they keep making me pay
into it and I'm not going to see any of
it because the dadgum things are screwed
up but other than that it's just an
aggravation
I'm not sitting and worrying about
Social Security's whether I get to eat
or not why well save some money invested
got some money and that's what I want
you to do is get some money not because
money is important but because money
buys you dignity and that you get to
take care of yourself in your golden
years oh and by the way you get to
change your family tree and take care of
your kids oh and by the way you get to
help others I've noticed hungry kids eat
better when you buy when somebody that
has money buys them food money buys food
and feeds hungry kids and then amazing
money drills as well in a town that
doesn't have a well money helps people
that are struggling so that that's what
you're doing your money is just a tool
I'm not here telling you you're going to
be happy if you have a million dollars
but I am telling you if you got that
million-dollar net worth if that's your
target or two million or five million or
whatever you're gonna be able to do a
lot more for yourself your family and
for others it's just a tool it buys
stuff that's all it does it doesn't buy
happiness you know I'm gonna be happy if
you have money if you're unhappy and you
get money you're just going to be big
and unhappy it's all you're gonna be
money just makes you more of what you
already are so we're not here to suggest
that money is the answer to everything
that is not what we're saying we're not
that shallow we don't want you guys to
be that shallow
but I'm also not going to buy into this
crap that somehow you're evil if you sat
around and saved money and invested and
you have the discipline and maturity to
live on less than you make and you saved
up money and now you've got a million
dollars so you're evil
well you're not evil you're disciplined
you're a person of high moral character
there's nothing evil about that so we've
got to stop calling success evil it's a
dumb pattern we have in parts of this
culture some of you morons out there
decided success is evil and you're just
[ __ ] that's all you are it's not evil
it's not we need to teach kids how to be
successful teach the next generation how
to be successful what have you got to do
how do you hit your goals why is it
important to hit your goals instead of
wandering around like a freakin zombie
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you